other share an alpha then marry a beta  yeah that's true i'll kill  foreign guys  like certain guys don't actually  understand because  guys do struggle with getting girls  nowadays and they don't understand that  yo a girl will just she'll have she'll  share a alpha guy before she even comes  to you  and  and i think that's that's why red pill  is so important because guys just have  to realize  what kind of predicament that they're in  and i think once you realize the kind of  predicament that you're in and if you  feel like you're in a you're in a  terrible position that's your that's  your kind of like your cue to stop you  know get get up and start doing about it